oliver jones merci de nous recevoir chez
vous
est venue d'un honneur vraiment un livre
de jeunesse que le piano dans votre vie
ça a été comme le meilleur ami que vous
avez découvert très jeune
naturellement pour moi j'étais tout beau
tout ça parce que j'ai commencé à la
hausse de 2,1 deuxième hypothèse
est celle où j'étais le plus jeune de sa
fille
à part un amas ma mère a trouvé que
j'étais trop bu six
filles
avec des cd de
de princesse
comme sa
vie ni
m'attacher en avant le prix hainaut
les amateurs de jazz peuvent remercier
la mère de livres john d'avoir attaché
son fils un banc de piano
savait-elle que le petit oliver
possédait l'oreille absolue cette
faculté rare même chez les musiciens de
reconnaître immédiatement
c'est pas faux mais
dans ma tête c'était quelque chose
facile passé
date en quelque chose pour la première
fois
puis les jouer
quand j'ai commencé de 1er et 2 mai puis
j'ai fait mon premier concert à st grand
c'était à l'église parce que vous
pouviez type j'étais trop jeune
évidemment pour aller dans les bars
encore un stage l'appui dans les zones
non mais j'ai rempli dans mes bras à la
hausse de 9,1 j'ai commencé un plus tard
[Rires]
à 5 ans les verts donnent des petits
concerts dans l'église de son quartier à
9 ans il fait sa première performance
solo ou café saint michel le cabaret de
l'époque
enfin il a déjà l'intuition qu'il
gagnera sa vie en jouant du piano
il faut dire que très jeune il rencontre
celui qui deviendra son idole son maître
un ami oscar pill sont en fait au début
on les veut ne voit que les mains du
grand ce gars je me souviens tous vos
j'avais 4-5-1 vire nous on avait tous
vos tenues
judy on avait toujours d'hui les
concerts des chantages
et pianiste
on peut de toute analyse via
à ce que vous mettez dans
via
[Musique]
sony vu 10 mai
il nomme
des d'ascq pour celles qui comprennent à
pau comment tu pouvais
pour toucher les lits d'une opa la voix
c'est de cette soirée là
j'ai jamais vu
personne jouer les pieds de comscore un
jeu loto mais chez nous
c'était au piano pic à main et un doux
et si large qu'elle paie on voyait que
il avait une technique
mpk
vous pourrez vivre un moment d'histoire
maintenant
65 ans plus tard ils se retrouveront sur
la même scène un concert organisé par
andré ménard du festival international
de jazz de montréal en 2004
le géant oscar pill le sun un des plus
grands pianistes de jazz jouent avec son
voisin d'enfance le virtuose oliver
jones
[Musique]
les concerts avec as car c'était quelque
chose etc serait pour moi parce que
personne ne le savait mais quand j'avais
pris ma retraite
je pour touches de piano pendant cinq
filles en dream a parlé il m'a parlé un
jour weezy quel suspense
si on fait un concert avec oscar
victoire
city
béziers higgott à l'appel mandanda
de quelques euros à jouer à paris avec
ma
femme
je pense que ça m'a pris une demi heure
je prends le téléphone
ok
oui à 12 apple a sky visiter
à
pied
et s'est inscrit
à
pts
j'ai jamais joué avec pascal
[Musique]
ascari et
j'étais toujours est faux mais si jamais
ils n'ont que ce soit ait quelqu'un qui
fait seulement musique laissez pas
d'espacé caspienne ou non - work hard
copy
les parents de livres john sont
originaire de la barbade pour le jeune
zhang un jeune noir dans la petite
bourgogne à montréal
la musique aura été dit il un antidote
au racisme
adolescence et à valleyfield que john
commencera sa première carrière de
pianiste hôtels et c'est là qu'il
rencontre une québécoise blanche et
francophones monique qui deviendra sa
femme est ce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune
noir de saint lary c'est plus facile ou
plus difficile que pour vous à l'époque
une famille noire dans ses arrêts or
pour ben ali s'était pas difficile pour
les autres parce que
80% de et noir à montréal
je serai dans cet endroit via un canal
tout le monde j'ai rempli dans les
maisons de
presque tout le monde qui se les rues
pauvres eux aussi davantage dans sa là
j'ai commencé de que par les français
aussi donc vais pas souffert de sceaux
veut pas se faire de discrimination des
ports anp non ya pas dans ma tête assad
n'a
pas sa place à
j'ai appris que vous avez fait vos
premières armes pour faire de l'argent à
valleyfield à l'hôtel la robe que je
pense que oui
vous avez rencontré votre femme à
l'époque où la vie demande en mariage au
début la ses parents voulaient pas
qu'elle marie 1 noir au nom puis vous
avez pas large et
c'était
comme à cannes surtout on s'est
rencontré l
aller avec 17 18 ans j'avais 20 ans on
était trois noirs à vérifier
d'amagou y en avait pas d'eau m dos cet
été alors même que l'église
voulait que
on vient voir les enfants à l'école
puis d'expliquer
qu'ils appellent d'afrique puis on dit
pourquoi l'afrique en a besoin
mais
c'est un déficit d'1 à presque chacun
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez tous eu
toutes ces histoires puis ces gens qui
disent il faut parler il ya trop de
préjugés il ya trop discrimination
envers les personnes assises et les
personnes noires ou qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'entendre
sango se sait c'est quelque chose qui il
reste toujours avec moi ah
j'en ai vu beaucoup de changements
pour juste ici au canada
et partout dans mon
anniv fait le tour du monde prêté cette
oliveraie
jamais personne qu'il aime mais insulter
pour moi c'était une grande occasion
résidence tous ces pays qui voit la
différence puis
même casse qui étaient en afrique
je voyais les réseaux pair toutes les
instances ce soir à table
puis les vieux camarade parler de toute
chose
il faut faire ici il faut frais sauf
et c'est presque tout les havrais qui
vais pas répéter
les mêmes choses
l'universel in our sam
universel faut arrêter de voir les
différences c'était normal pour les pour
les jeunes dès que curieux de pocono oui
oui
belge pour trouver son air à six
parce que ils m'ont trouvé des valeurs
j'ai jamais trouvé
à j'ai toujours gardé les affaires à
t'aimer par m
parlez souvent de
respecter
les gens quand j'allais d'un temps les
villages aux
les villes que je connaissais pour
personne
les minutes j'ai commencé défaut de
parler français
tout était
correct la langue c'est là que si on
voit que c'est important
la langue ça ça rejoint beaucoup les
gens qui comme la musique triste
et au piano en leur genre
un livre john jouent dans les clubs dans
les années 50-60 en anglais en français
il tissera des liens dans le monde de la
musique et du jazz en 63 il s'exile à
porto rico où il devient le directeur
musical du chanteur populaire un exil
qui va durer près de 20 ans avant que le
bassiste charles b roll le convaincre de
revenir à montréal
sa carrière de jazz va recommencer à ce
moment là suivront des enregistrements
d'alban détourner des prix toujours avec
la même bonne humeur qui le caractérise
il est fier mais pas pompeux ni orgueil
[Musique]
oliver jones habituellement les gens ont
l'image de musiciens de jazz des
problèmes d'alcool de drogue ont dit si
d'un milieu de barres d'alcool vous
jamais vous avez toujours été totalement
ça vous avez donc il est possible d
jazzman sans boire ou s'en prend de la
drogue
et le contre et b du monde qui titre ce
n'est pas un vrai jazz même pas ce que
te prends pas du coup
j'ai tout vous dire
qui un jour
et je suis ravi parce que
90e
et il vous
en cours ont noté que trek
mais
ce n'est jamais arrivé jusque là via
le grunge et à me toucher j'ai jamais
fumer un cigare et
cote 1 6 mai mais par ac
après l'argentine ses deux assesseurs
s'il n'est pas nécessaire d'aller jouer
dans la fumée dans beaucoup de whisky
autour de verrous vous jouiez aller
jouer avec des musiciens qui
a tout des soirées impactées à
il y en a d'autres qui qui peut pas et
nos deux
poissons potins qui s'élève une attaque
pomme tout
est prêt pour un code python je sais que
c'est un problème p g j
j'ai jamais vous dire quelque chose
qu'il avait
cru ans nous c'est moi et puis au delà
de ça vous êtes plus beaucoup de gens le
disent vous êtes resté le même le même
avec le grand succès des années 80 90
2000 vos voyages à l'étranger du son
vous êtes resté un homme bien un homme
humble nomme bien ça faisait jamais
monté à la tête en fait
un nom à fleury prao
je suis très très fier des des mavs y
est je pense le bon dieu qui met qui
m'aidait beaucoup
je suis pauvre de zee que je suis
vraiment
vraiment cheap
moi je trouve que
tout qu'est ce qui est passé dans ma vie
j'ai jamais été bonne à l'école
mais j'en ai eu toute une éducation
en travailler
en chine un
an trois fauteurs
trio
alors entre
elles
moi je trouve que j'étais l'homme le
plus riche a sûrement
rêvé président un ténor
iphone
3g
plus pop demander plus l'uvs et restez
vous même vous avez pas jouer un
personnage est pas devenu à regarde pas
devenu ce est pas devenue la grosse
vedette là c'est ça que les gens ne
vous aimez ces séries
ce n'est tout qu'est-ce que j'ai besoin
à fossano
nouveaux
et tenir un livre de georges ce que je
peux vous demander une faveur
est-ce que vous jouez des fois pour le
plaisir pour vous pour vos toiles de
fond lundi
qu'est-ce que vous joueriez un peu pour
nous oui oui à ces appareils sur une
embauche
je suis sûre
il y a quelque chose d'émouvant de voir
un livre de jean dans son salon à
montréal s'installer pour nous à son
piano
il ne joue plus très souvent et comme un
signe de gratitude envers son ami et
mentor la musique de scarpi lawson
remplir a magnifiquement la pièce
[Musique]
non
le
m
on
[Musique]
oh
on
à
voilà
bravo cette bourde ou jouer ça comme si
vous aviez jamais arrêtés
y en a
douze mois de support est à se voir
dans le bras b et c
puis c'est la sellor royal
merci d'avoir reçu chez vous au jour
tout le monde
est inquiet